des photos de son fils barring on a des
centaines
mais c'est une prise après la naissance
d'un de ces petits-enfants et sa
préférée des souvenirs déjà précieux
devenus inestimables depuis la mort de
barringf le 29 octobre 2011 en
Afghanistan
sa mère est toujours sous le choc hyper
à croire que son fils a vraiment été tué
le caporal-chef barring on était à son
deuxième séjour en Afghanistan le
parachutisme membre de l'infanterie
participaient à la formation des soldats
afghan quand l'autobus blindé de l'OTAN
à bord duquel il se trouvait a été la
cible d'un kamikaze une mission qui
devait être moins dangereuse que sa
première
choisit jeune la carrière du militaire
après un passage chez les cadets une
surprise pour sa famille ou personne
avant lui n'avait fait carrière dans
l'armée
mon fils voulait toujours dit tout le
monde c'est pour ça qu'il avait choisi
une carrière militaire raconte sa mère
en vigueur de 2000m 2014 la mission à
l'Afghanistan a été la plus longue
opération de combat de l'histoire
militaire canadienne Barringer fait le
158e et dernier soldat canadien mort
dans le pays
en portant la croix d'argent Candy
griffe a accepté le titre qu'elle
portera pendant un an pour tous les
autres morts durant cette longue
opération
par la mort de son fils est immense mais
les souvenirs eux ne se limitent pas aux
photos dans le cimetière près de chez
elle ou repose barring un véhicule
blindé a été installé à sa mémoire un
banc pour tout si son nom sur le terrain
de son ancienne école secondaire
les gens doivent être conscients du
sacrifice de mon fils croix madame
greffe de barren et des autres soldats
morts en devoirs les souvenirs sont
gardés précieusement en portant la croix
d'argent Candy grève veut maintenant les
partager avec tous les Canadiens
ici Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada Edmonton